بعد زفاف الملكي جيل بايدن في مصر
والباتشينو ينتظر طفلا جديدا اليكم الابرز
في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
لا يزال التفاعل مستمرا على منصات التواصل
في العالم العربي مع اصداء زفاف ولي عهد
الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
والاميره نجوى الحسين الذي شهدته عمان في
الاول من حزيران يونيو 2023 وتفاعل
المتابعون على نحو المتزايد مع اللقطات
التي رصدتها وسائل الاعلام من الزفاف
الملكي الاطلالات الراقيه واللحظات
المؤثره ومشاركه النجوم العرب للاردنيين
فرحهم بالحسين حروف الاسامي الخاتم
[موسيقى]
ومما تفاعل معه المتابعون الزفه الاردنيه
السعوديه التي غناها فنان العرب محمد عبده
والفنان الاردني عمر العبد اللات وكتب
كلماتها الشاعر السعودي صالح الشادي والتي
روى كواليسها في مقابله حصريه مع بالعربيه
وكشف من خلالها عن علاقه ويب تربطه باسره
العروس السعوديه والعائله الملكيه
الهاشميه انعكست بشكل عاطفي على كلمات
الزفه بالعين بين الرمش والرمش يا حسين
شفنا القمر ساطع وشفناه رجوه
[موسيقى]
كما شارك المطرب الاماراتي حسين الجسمي
بالاحتفالات بزفاف الملكي في حفل احياه في
المدرج الروماني بعمان انشد فيه اغنيته
المحببه للاردنيين العالي
[موسيقى]
وبعد حضورها مراسم الزفاف الملكي الاردني
توجهت السيده الامريكيه الاولى جيل بايدن
الى مصر في زياره خاصه زارت فيها الجامع
الازهر في المحروسه ووجهت رساله بعد
زيارتها عبر حسابها الرسمي على تويتر قالت
فيها من خلال فهم ديانات بعضنا البعض
اعتقد انه يمكننا ايجاد ارضيه مشتركه
وتوحيدنا برغبتنا في الحقيقه والحب
والعداله والشفاء كما زارت جيل بايدن
اهرامات الجيزه وذلك بالتزامن مع ذكرى
ميلادها الثاني والسبعين
وفي مصر كرم المجلس القومي للمراه نجمات
وصناع الدراما المصريه الداعمه لقضايا
المراه والتي عرضت في موسم دراما رمضان
الماضي وكان من بين المكرمين منى زكي عن
دورها في مسلسل تحت الوصايه ونيل كريم عن
دورها في مسلسل عمله نادره وروجينا عن
مسلسل ستهم ودنيا سمير غانم عن مسلسل جاد
سليمه واخرين بينهم صناع مسلسل حضره
العمده
واخيرا تفاعل متابعون منصات التواصل على
نطاق واسع عالميا مع خبر انتظار الممثل
الباتشينو البالغ من العمر 83 عاما مولودا
من صديقته الكويتيه نور الفلاح حسب ما اكد
ممثله لسانا وتبلغ نور من العمر 29 عاما
اي انها تصهره باربعه وخمسين عاما تقريبا
وسيكون هذا الطفل رابع اولادي النجم
العالمي